[Laughter]
[Music]
No
I'm gonna check with you
[Music]
you
[Laughter]
what back [__] uncle Joey and
his main little [__] Jewish friend
Lisa had on a Wednesday night you're
lonely you're sitting at what the [__]
am I gonna watch on TV well your prayers
were answered
it's not a TV show it's a periscope show
[__] we're sitting back in listening
to the wall getting really hit a few
stars you don't have enough tonight but
we do have two hundred milligram
chuckling boss he's I'm saying so it
always gets [__] made up somewhere
along the line cuz that's how we were we
got six we got got thousand [__]
milligrams between us and the world late
into his brain but what best we can hear
you gotta hit the [__] month gotta
hit your [__] goals every month and I
got gold
I got a certain by the milligrams couple
nights a week sir
took the beat [__] pumping got two
dead and three dead so we open up to 53
City five blondish 650s an apéritif
police I am Joey Diaz yeah what's a good
night without some great weed we got
some more [__] cookies from Brett
periscope and we've also got this [__]
here the critical [__] whatever a
critical condition critical mass it
don't matter
I did one bong in I'm hearing [__]
voices bound hey you
that's it but beautiful day to be alive
I hope you [__] are happy your
families are well your jobs you know
it's a [__] up time of the year you
got to get ready
divided we fall
this [__] guy is albeit drooling all
over some ethos still he say you don't
even know water these are 125 the two
hundreds are really strong just like
that we've got no time for thinking we
have no time to bleed you got no time to
do nothing the clock is ticking and you
only got so many [__] heartbeats so
while these hearts are [__] beatin you
gotta have a good time and we got these
things we got the 50 milligram ones
that's 150 that's 300 we got if we meet
yeah 300 for you and 300 from it listen
dream read it's so far today it's the
holidays here every [__] day my hands
off [__] I don't give a [__] I'm no
fashion model I'm just here to talk to
you cops up it's the string down the
Wednesday night mmm just like that
nutritious delicious and [__] filled
with love I'll tell you what one of my
favorite items just to chill with the
smoke dope is the war I don't know why I
tell this [__] thing you know why cuz
I'm committed to [__] tuna to was
something like that when I was into the
wall 19 [__] 79 November tremendous
[__] album they never recovered from
that it's too [__] powerful live alone
Annapolis
when they vacuumed this carpet there's
gonna be a quarter on up like a quarter
[__] pound more [__] is falling on
this floor any other foreign American
that's just a baby but this is good
marijuana I told you [__] but
one I do call me late last night and
said you gotta see this for paint right
now
critical mass even put nine one one and
this shit's [__] killing
[__] I got like a half ounce of
it it took an eighth time I'm saving the
rest who want Isis attacks
I see everybody's having a good time
everybody sparking not that bad not that
you drive
that's right beautiful man we went to
the we've stored 10 it was in my car
bacon I just took a nap now it's [__]
seven o'clock back together
there are Vera what has become of you
tomorrow night flappers [__] I'm
doing another workout one hour $10
insane don't [__] around Friday The
Improv Saturday The Improv run all
[__] week [__] working Sunday
we got a podcast
EBI I got a mix and matching either
thousand things you know it's just too
much I said guys it's just too much on
the [__] plate look at look at that
right there you might to call [__]
out once on this some [__] smoke got
it uncle Joey's taking it to the hoop
tonight on Wednesday night whose turn is
at least I asked time he hasn't even
this is tremendous this week
only doesn't mommies would be so [__]
happy
you need two buckets in this week tops
I'm Trent I'm always in training to top
I brush my teeth and I still got
something my [__] tooth I hate that
[__] but we're gonna do people you don't
say you can sit that stabbed me you
could join it I don't care I got to
always tell you put on stairs to the
basement your uncle's got some [__]
pills - down there take two of those
[__] in the cocktail roll the
joint that's it you'll be in bed by
10:00 [__] 31 of those foot pills
whatever he's got his big toe swollen
from [__] eating red sauce we're
gonna [__] this they take those little
pills for pains to Lausanne an amaretto
a milk and a [__] bong hit and they
won't see you till tomorrow at 6:00 a.m.
you understand you won't even get the
best tonight you'll piss all over
yourself this [__] which is not bad I'm
not a bad [__] time people all right
it's not bad when you piss yourself you
just save two hours are you [__]
here we go Lisa I am this is the Beast
of beasts this retha this is the [__]
the first Chinese guys smoked right here
yes there we go mistakenly on a [__]
world of life here
take that thing off okay here we go this
is the one people this is the torch I'm
a rule right here this is the one this
is the real [__] people this is from
Uncle Tom's Cabin this reason it's going
through your body it's what it's
tremendous I'm Tanya this is the voices
you see a dead grandmother walking
around this is this dish it you want but
it only sold we think that's the tank of
death right there on the bottom
don't ever [__] throw that [__] up
that's the collective I'm saying that's
right there it's like when you take a
piece of [__] you break it in half it
smells even worse because you cut until
the rule in the [__] same thing the
bottom of the bum the bottom of that
[__] thing
if you're dealing with joint bananas
Vera what has become of you it's time
for chocolate that's what they don't
like Joe I don't know what this is nice
job this is the data from the people who
make [__] Cibo truth right then only
sold in Denver premium 200 lab tested
hybrid THC he's like [__] six of
these is when you shake him leave
leastly
I told you that this we this we [__]
lowers your blood pressure this week
takes you to a different psychological
critical mass a rhenium right now run
over there right now
Tonya I wouldn't lie to you [__]
this little clue you're feeling before I
go
you're gonna you're not gonna be sorry
gonna say Joey what the [__] did you
give me it's a ton of people the props
are a ball of mass we from Northern
California is coming down in the next
two months we're gonna be smoking [__]
that's gonna be killing [__] is
the next batch of the future
okay I have to keep moving around we
won't take the bar home because then
we'll bus tomorrow we won't get high on
the bottom I spoke yesterday you know me
I'm always mixing and matching joints
bones pipes many many many mysteries you
know and don't make of it
that's pretty good it's really good it's
like the chocolate [__] agreement
people walk out of the restaurant think
wheels chocolate with something green in
the middle and you're popping in your
mommy I walk back to steal three more
that's what this is only with 200
milligrams of THC if you're in the
Denver area
get yourself achievements you or
[__] dab a bar and tell them
uncle Joey said your concept and that's
it and that's hitting that dad I've been
doing my TI cbpo I do it twice in the
morning and at night before I go to bed
I got two types I got the guy from I got
the friend I got the stuff from my
friend Chris global the really really
high price good clean THC but I got some
other GCB be willow [__] THC in it to
take it to the [__] parts where you
need it
think of impossible I've been taking it
I'm already getting the mentor I see the
early signs I hear voices even I'm not
smoking pot I pay attention that's the
main thing anybody can hear voices pay
attention to mr. with the earphones on
let them [__] shine it's like they
did a line of coke they won't shut the
[__] up and then when I go to bed they
talk a little bit but I breathe through
my nose I don't hear a real answer and
then sitting that's that [__]
everybody's along the [__] [__]
stone side
this car mooch is calling in tonight she
will be over at EBI on Sunday she's
going up against Benson and this is wife
this is the second match I think God
let's climb which one the first one so
EBI is sunday gonna my budeau videos i
don't know what the price is but uh
they've been sensational last three or
four walls have been great to be honest
it if you can't show up for the off the
Athena I suggest you go to [__] new
videos and watch it wait for another
bonding dog going training we go find
Bob on here with the [__] best we
don't give a [__] take out your bombs
get that flag this is American as it
[__] is comfortably numb' a bomb we'd
and the American flag are you [__]
kidding me
are you [__] kidding me who could
stop after that [__] recipe of death
that's it the sicarios are doing I
didn't know you were serious [__] to
be dealing will you to God if I say it
if I'm not serious always training here
we're going to the murky waters we're in
the murky waters [__] like the guy
told Jax teller
[Music]
take it to the boot please over there
there there you go see like a champ see
you [__] you're Nadine hang up
now [__]
look at my boy see who gives a [__] I
burnt them off 18 times Obama that's
laughable that's why where's the wolf
man in town you guys I'm dropping on you
right now you look for regular mom you
say uncle Joey sent me I want the
[__] critical mass this is
technically for the murky waters time
it's Wednesday night I'm not gonna
[__] bother you people with nonsense
with shitty [__] weed I don't do that
type of the minute
and you're sitting there you wanna be a
[__] politician suck my dick
Thomas hitches don't blow clouds like
that [__]
and that's it and that's dead what we're
gonna do is wind up being a little bit
go to youtube.com slash c / mad flavor
Joe Diaz and tap into the podcast you
know I love you [__] with all
my heart without you guys we'd have dick
so thank you for being a part of this we
throw there you go we'll see you stay
black
be happy